as an NYPD sergeant as an Afghan as a
Muslim as a human being I had to do what
I had to do few days ago I was far gone
46th Street Broadway with one of my
officers officer svorski 11:30 at night
a car came biased and taught something
inside the vehicle after suppose he goes
boss this is a bomb the light went on
stop making noise and look around there
were a lot of people there thousands of
thousands of people so I had two options
leave the van and just take cover and
call bomb squad or take this device out
of here and save hundreds not thousands
of lives a split-second decision I was
like I can't do it I can't leave I
cannot be selfish I got to do what I
gotta do but the car drive saw driving
that was asking God if it happens please
I don't want to feel pain it was
flashing faster and faster I got a
corner of 46th Street and 6th Avenue I
saw there were many people stop the van
I grabbed the device from officer Volk
his hand I asked him to leave the van
and I placed in the sidewalk I think God
no one got hurt I thank God my partner
is safe I wasn't worried about myself at
all the only thing went through my mind
the promise that made my daughter
I'm gonna come home in the night it went
through my mind like I'm breaking that
promise but I'm sure she's gonna be part
of it
Oh